have you ever wondered if your dog loves
you or your partner more well there's a
simple test to find out just stand
parallel to your partner and have a
third person holding your dog at least
15 feet away when everyone is ready
release the dog and see who it runs to
each partner can use any kind of
gestures or calls but they can't move
from their spot and they can't use
anything like toys or treats this is our
dog penny the pretty Frenchy penny is a
really silly dog she loves balls you're
gonna thank you
so only the finest cheese's I think
penny will choose mommy because mommy
raises her she feeds her
I think she'll choose me because we have
an awesome time this is pixel pixel
pretty much gets whatever she wants look
at this face okay you say no easy no you
don't get everything you want don't
listen to him I think pixel will choose
me there's no way she's gonna pick me
and this is Posey I was not really a dog
person before we got her but falling in
love for sure so she loves me if she
doesn't come to me it's gonna hurt
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
he totally cheated I bet you he was like
sitting there and giving your treat Oh
morning what she's looking for
[Music]
I expected as much I guess you don't
love him as much as we thought right
Betty yeah he said he had to put his hit
on his shoes the cheese bribes obviously
didn't work thought I had it figured out
better had a dialed in good job no good
mommy loves you
oh now you want me to hold you I see how
it is he won I won he had pockets of
Allah treats at home he was like packing
away secret treats so he could give her
treats and butter her up all weekend do
you love me more yes you do more than
mommy yeah and we need a rematch I feel
very loved I feel a little betrayed you
could tell there at the end she was
looking you know in between both of us
very last minute she chose Raquel which
was what I kind of expected to happen we
just have an intense bond little jealous
to be honest
[Music]
[Music]